Yeah.
Hi, good afternoon, Randy.
Hey, how are you?
I'm great, it's like you were asking. How have you been?
Good, I can't believe another week has gone by.
Oh yeah. When we're busy, things, you know, just fly by.
Hey, Brandy, I thank you.
They do.
Is it 1:30 where you're at?
Two 30.
Oh yeah, you're in MST. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, Mountain Time.
Okay.
All right, so is Amber also joining in? Should we expect him or?
I don't think she will be today. She's at a customer site doing a project. So she might pop in, she might not. But we can get started without her.
Okay.
All right, sure, absolutely.
I hope you know everything is going good. You know, when we are busy, so, you know, as Kevin said, so we are busy, you know, it must be good busy.
Who?
OK, Evan, anything from your end before we start off?
No, I'm good.
Ohh.
Oops, sorry.
Yeah, no, no worries, I mean, I'm good. Thank you.
Were you able to say something?
Yeah, I just had a couple quick items. We didn't have the call that was before this one since Ronald was out. So I know we had the interview with Sophie and that went really well. So I'm just waiting to talk to Ketan to see about doing one other interview with her. And there were a couple other resumes that Ronald had sent me for Patrick and Cairo. So I was hoping to
Mmh.
move forward with getting some interviews scheduled for them as well, just to see who we would prefer out of the three to be a good fit for our team.
Sure, I'll definitely coordinate with our team and get this schedule, you know, as quickly and as soon as possible. Vishal, thank you for joining in.
So, uh...
Hey, very good evening.
Hey, Vishal, thank you for joining. So, Benny, I'm a little confused. So, the other resumes that you're referring to, are they from us?
Yeah.
Next.
Yes, they are tier threes that Ronald sent over.
Oh, okay, okay, okay. Yeah, I figured.
So I believe there were three resumes, if I'm not wrong, Brandy, right?
That's correct. We had one tier 2, which was Sophie, who we interviewed with last week, and that went really well. And so Patrick and Cairo are the tier threes. We just wanted to interview them and see what would be a best fit for us to move forward with an additional person.
Yep, sounds good.
Okay, no worries. Yeah, I believe Shashank should have all the information, Kanav, in case if you need to coordinate with him. I think we can do that after this call. Yep.
Yep.
Thank you so much.
Absolutely.
Thank you, Brandy, for sharing this, and Vishal, anything from your end before we start off with a presentation?
No, no, no, sir, please get blessings from Andy and go ahead. I'm all good.
All right. Thank you. Thank you, Team. So officially, once again, welcome to our Monday weekly business review call. And I'm sharing my screen. Let me know once it's there on your screen.
Play Dharam.
Here we go.
Thank you. So, yeah, so this is from May 11th to 15th.
From graphical standpoint, it is still the same. I mean, we have not made much changes, but yeah, so agenda items will remain the same. We have highlights, performance analysis, ITBD service offerings, AI by design.
But.
Holiday schedule way forward with up to USA and recap, which we usually send after this call via email.
So again, please feel free to chime in. Your feedback is always valuable for us. And wherever you think there is a summary of improvement or you have anything to say, we'll be glad to hear from you. Thank you. And this is for everyone, our internal team as well as for you. Thank you.
I capture not much, but some of the highlights of Phoebe and Shiv that both exceeded their productivity. So at ITBD, I know in your environment, you already told us, so you focus more on both of these numbers, either billable or non-billable. But I see that.
Their billable is also going good because this is ultimately giving revenue to the company. So they're giving good billable time. We'll be reviewing this on the following slides. And Phoebe has improved on her TRL by 10%, although ITBD target is still 80%.
Huh?
But we'll discuss more on this. However, she did do better on this in the previous week.
And they are proactive as per feedback from you as well, and for Amber, and when I connect with them as well. So I get to hear. Whenever I ask a question, so they right away, most of the time they do have an answer, why and, you know, how that particular thing is going.
So, they decided they satisfied me with those answers. Before we move further, I would like to know about your observations overall in this week, Randy.
So this week we actually had some feedback from the customers about Phoebe and Shiv, and it was all positive. The customers see in their notes that, you know, if they hit a wall, they're reaching out to the team. They're seeing other team members' names popping up in the time entries, the collaboration and the working together. So
It's really given the customers a nice sense. We save the warm and fuzzies. They're happy knowing that, you know, Phoebe and Shiv might be the ones on the phone, but they have the mothership behind them that they can tap into if they ever need help. So that's been really great to see from the customer side.
Wow, great. Thank you for sharing that with us.
That really made my day. I mean, although that was close to end of the day, it, you know, is in time, but you really did. Thank you.
Okay.
Ohh.
Moving on to performance analysis. So, in this week, previously, as I showed you, so Phoebe was struggling in documenting some of the some of the entries when she didn't know exactly where this time needs to go in. So, this time, there...
Yeah.
total productivity, including billable and non-available, that accumulates 200%. So they know where exactly, you know, that particular time needs to be entered. So their billable, billable of VB remain 88.03% and her non-available remain 11.97%.
and shares 87.44% and non-available 12.56%, which is impressive to my standpoint. At ITBD, we have a target of 80%. However, we'll let you hear from you as always.
What?
Before we move further, anything from you? I know you may not be working with them directly, but sorry to ask you these questions.
Uh, I...
No, no, that's fine. Yeah, I've just been seeing them collaborate, post questions, pulling tickets. They've worked on a variety of different things. So it's good to see that, you know, they're so proactive about everything and getting the work done and supporting the customers.
Thank you, Brandy, for sharing this.
Moving on to ticket resolve rate, TRR. So again, the target is 80% and Phoebe here, you can see the previous week, although we know that she was on PTS as well. And so this week, in comparison to the previous week, she stood 60.98%
Yeah.
percent his TRR and Shiv little drop by showing 2 percent, 63.64 percent. So when I asked them, what is the reason? I mean, are you struggling with anything? Is there anything you need training on? They said,
My focus is to, they should handle, they should close the Helpdesk ticket. Any ticket that they work on with the user should be completed within 30 to 35 minutes. But so any ticket that is taking more than 40 minutes, that needs to be taken care of, that needs to be reported.
They should voice out, raise their hand, they need assistance, so the team is aware that, you know, they must help them in order to enhance user experience. So they told me that some of those tickets were user onboardings, which...
Yeah.
does take 1 1/2 hours to two hours. That's one thing. So Shiv has four tickets out of those, and Phoebe has, you know, total 7 tickets, which took more than 40 minutes. So out of, she had three to four tickets of user onboardings last week.
And apart from that, there was one issue wherein multiple users were affected. So she said she needed to deal with, she needed to check with the other team members. For instance, she was sharing, there was one ticket from Girls INC. There was a...
Mhm.
Uh, yeah, so there was boarding, uh, nearland, uh, Sanchez, uh, that was the kind of ticket, so you know...
you know, which took more time. And she had a ticket with the Lake Rio community, wherein MFA was recently enforced by the client. So, which is why, you know, the team was not aware of what exactly needs to be done and where they needed to check.
Mhm.
Yeah.
So she said, I was completely unaware that it was Google Workspace. So they needed, he researched, then he worked with Team, and so ultimately they should go, you know, go resolve that took care of it. So similar kind of thing. So anything that comes for the first time, newly.
It may take time. It does take time. Otherwise, I hope they're doing well. Because my focus is to understand and monitor if they need any training or to understand anything. We should be upskilling themselves on those particular pieces.
Mm.
Anything else from your end, Andy, you would like to add?
Yeah, I mean, we'd like to encourage everybody to step out of their comfort zone and try some of those tickets that they might not be familiar with. So I mean, I'm impressed and glad that she is pulling some of those and understand that if it takes a little bit longer, she's learning something new and she'll be able to support that customer better going forward. So perfect.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you for sharing that. And Sameer, I just noticed you jumped in. Welcome to this call. Anything from your end that you would like to add?
I just wanted to say hi to my good friend Brandy. I just appeared on her call randomly. The other day as well, I just randomly joined. I just wanted to make sure that everything is going good. Do I know that Vishal and Kanav are here and so is Gagan is here, so I'm sure the service side is going good.
Very quickly, Brandy, I'll just again loop it into other call. I have one question that because I was working with my Pre Sales team and not to detail, if you can just close your screen, Gagan, just for a moment. And not to detail the momentum of this call, Brandy, I have
Right now, two positions open with me. One is for a sort of an L2 like or L1 plus, what you have as of now. And the other one is for procurement. Is there any other position which is open, right? An L3 or L2 plus, anything like that? Or is it that you want to pursue in future?
Yeah.
We do have a couple resumes for L3s. And I was just talking to the team here about getting those interviews scheduled sometime this week as well. We aren't quite sure if we want to go L2 or L3 right now. So we did the interview with Sophie, which went great. And so we'd like to meet with these two as well, and then just kind of check with the team, see which way we want to go, what kind of support that they're looking to
have backed them up. We did have a couple people leave the company recently, so that's where we're trying to look to maybe fill for being remote support. That way the team that's local can really focus on the on-site appointments instead, while the team from ITBD will be able to back them up with all the remote calls.
Ohh.
Understood.
No, this gives me a clear idea. I just want to help get the tank checked that those L2s are available as of now or not, right? Because it's so fast, this MSP world, that they could have been interviewed with other people as well. So I need to check and go back to my team, the police sales team, if they are available or not, which was shared with you. If not, then I'll send you
Yeah.
Mhm.
two fresh resumes and if you can tell Vishal or me or Gagan the times when you want to take interviews for those two, I'm more than happy. And again, I'm okay if you like to place both, I'll be more than happy. Okay.
Okay.
Right, sounds good.
Alright, awesome. Gagan, so sorry to break the flow over to you again.
Thank you, Sameer.
No, that's going to be okay, Sameer. Well, thank you for kind of chiming in.
Vishal, you did you want to say anything?
No, no, I'm all good. Please, please go ahead. Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Resharing my screen, so I'll let you know once it's visible to everyone.
Alright, you see it.
Thank you.
So yeah, we did cover that. So moving on to...
ITBD service offerings. I don't have to spend much time on it. I know you already know it. Oh, Rick jumps at right at time. Hi, Rick.
But.
Okay.
I'm sure you, we have discussed with Brandy, and I think Keenan, you know, has been informed yet, so it is confirmed already, so...
Hi, everyone.
They are coming to build it.
Yeah.
Yes.
So I think going forward we can remove the slide.
Okay, thank you. And we have talked about this one as well. So whenever you think there's a requirement of Team GPS for any of these features, you may always scan this QR code and I think we'll be right there to assist you with the demo. Thank you.
Yep.
This thing is cover Rick already, I believe.
Rick.
Yeah, I think here we are already working. Parth is just working for the further because we got those requirements from Keenan. He's just making sure before the next demo he's ready with everything. So yeah, we are already on track.
Perfect. Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you. So why ITBD calendar? Nothing much interesting on this. So these, I hope, compulsory holidays have already been marked on at your end on your calendar. And this is the upcoming holiday, option holiday, which is Diwali, and that too.
Yeah.
I mean, months apart from now is in the month of November. And but do please do let us know if there is anything on if they need to support business on any particular day, we'll speak to them and they can get complimentary of later on.
Thank you.
My way forward has not changed, but I was thinking to add just one more point, you know, after this conversation today. First of all, Phoebe and Shift should remain focused on the KPI as they are improving already. So I, my emphasis is to just, you know.
for them to continue focus on their KPIs, meeting their numbers and upscaling themselves wherever they think there's an improvement required.
and ITBD to continue to encourage, which means me, Vishal, Kevin, to support team in identifying any areas where they can add value. Yeah, that was one thing. I thought, you know, I need to add an extra point, but I did cover this already. So, Brandy,
Do we proactively update SOPs or does any specific person has this kind of a job to review those SOPs in an update timely manner? Because I understand when I was working with one of my partners, they said because...
These days, the environment technology is so dynamic. After every six or eight months, things do change. You know, Microsoft is very frequent in making changes, or so do the other portals. So even the portal interfaces change, so do the steps change.
IND.
So should we review these steps or I mean, I don't know if they're doing it already, someone in your environment, but if you need assistance from PB or Chev, I mean, they would love to be a part of that as well. As for their availability and bandwidth so they can be utilized.
Okay.
because it will not only help them meeting their productivity as well as at the same time, if they think then they are struggling to find a particular piece of information that is a little bit, because they are new in the environment, the old team, maybe they have done this plenty of times earlier, so they know what exactly is where.
So, but sometimes they need to collaborate or, you know, bug team for those particular PCs. So, I was checking with, I said, even if there's a minor thing that you're not able to find in the SOP, that means, I mean, you can suggest those steps with a team member that this is something, you know, I struggle, so if this can be updated.
Yeah.
So going forward, this can help you. Yeah, because at ITBD, our emphasis is only to, you know, do better every day. I mean, it should never be stagnant on working on daily, same thing every day, what we're doing. We are starting day with tickets and ending day with the ticket.
So, anything we can improve, we can bring better changes in the environment. I think we must focus on those things. I think this is how you will also be noticing how we are adding value in your environment, not just, you know, doing tickets for alerts, service requests, or...
incidents.
The last point, but not the least, so ITBD is responsibility is to make team feel like home, family, to always, you know, meet, have get together with them on weekly basis, or from ITBD organization standpoint or from company side.
We get, we get, you know, funds for our quarterly connects. So we, you know, as you know, we go out and dine together. We have lunch or dinner together. So this time, if Rick or anyone will be a part of this, so we'll send you pictures of those get together collaboration and you'll see how we do it.
Yeah.
Thank you. I believe that was clearly all from my end. I'm unsharing my screen and anything from Brandy as well as from Vishal, Rick and Kevin.
Nothing from my son.
I'm good, thank you.
I'm good.
I'm good as well. No complaints. If Brandy's happy, we all are happy, I believe. So thank you so much.
Vaid.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, so thank you. One thing, what Kevin highlighted the last time, so I know next week on the 25th we have a holiday.
So Brandy, should we move the cadence of this call? Vishal, this is what we were discussing last time. So it's already been 1 1/2 months with Uptime USA. So shall we move the cadence to biweekly now?
Yeah, I think that would be perfect.
Okay, that'd be great. So I'll change the cadence of this culture bi-weekly and I'll send you the invite going forward from two weeks from 1st of June.
Yep.
Perfect.
All right, so that is all for my IND team. Looking forward to hearing from you. Yeah.
Yep.
Only, only.
Only one request from my side, Wendy. I'm sure I'm just going to reiterate what you have already heard from Gagan and Kanav. We are going to make this Y-weekly call, but if you have any concern, please don't wait for this call to happen. Right, just drop an email or we all, I mean, you know, me, Kanav and Gagan, we are always one ping or one email away if you need any help.
Yep.
So I appreciate your kind support and continuity for this business. Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you.
One last thing, sorry, before we drop off. I just want to double check, Ben, is your team's federation working?
Yes, yes.
Okay, okay. I know you must really be tied up with a lot of things sometimes. Or, you know, and we do have time difference as well at the same time. We have three hour difference. So, you know, the other day, Phoebe was late. So I just wanted to double check. I mean, if he sent a communication to you, I know, even if you do not respond, but you do receive those. Did you receive my message that day?
Okay, alright.
Email is the best way to reach Brandy. So just to let you know, so they are not regularly logged into Teams. So when they logged in, then they check it. So it happened earlier with me and that's how I get to know from Brandy. So yeah, I think the best practice is just drop a message on Teams and hand to end drop an email.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I try to check Teams regularly. We use Zoom internally for communication and video calls. So Teams, I forget to open up every day sometimes.
Oh, yes.
Okay. Well, thank you, Rick, and thank you, Brandy, for letting us know. And yeah, so this way we understand, you know, which way we need to proceed further accordingly. Thank you. So, I'll keep emails as well as phone call if necessary.
Okay, thank you. Yeah, and Phoebe messaged me too, so I was good to go. She let me know she was running about 10 minutes late, and I appreciated that.
Thank you. I really do appreciate your collaboration and cooperation with us. So thank you very much, team, for joining us. And I hope we'll be getting some more positive news and updates after two weeks. Thank you for joining in, team. Have a great day. Until then.
Thanks, everyone. Bye-bye.
Yeah, bye-bye.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, Dean. Bye.